welcome welcome to the uh Stanford S 24w
course um today I will be your guest
instructor uh on behalf of Yuri my name
is Josan and you might find more
information on myself on the website I
also was one of the had TA in the
previous off offering and so I'm
relatively familiar as a course um today
I'll be very excited to give the topic
of graph Network to you all um in this
lecture so let's give a quick uh recap
of what we have learned in the previous
lecture so the key concept we learn is
node embedding our intuition is that we
want to encode nodes in the network into
low dimensional Vector space in
particular we want to learn a function
that takes an input graph and embed that
into low dimensional no ining space here
we project into two Dimension and the
key problem of machine learning graph is
how do we Define this function
f so here's a recap of how to encode a
node we have um uh the goal is to define
a similarity function um that can uh
represent the similarity in the network
and we want to approximate in the
embeding space and we really need to
Define two things the first is the
similarity function represent how two
nodes are closed together in the network
another thing is the encoder function
that basically tells us how to map the
node in the graph into embedding
space and there are two uh key component
here uh we have encoder that map the
node into embedding and decoder that
Define this similarity
function so the encod function will take
the node um as input and generate
embedding in the D dimensional space and
similarity function will specify the
relationship ship in the network and
also Express in the loss function as a
decoder and how do we Define similarity
uh last lecture we talk about random
work based similarity function for
example suppose two nodes they co-occur
in a short random work then we think uh
these two nodes are similar so that's
one way to define similarity and we can
also come up with other way to define
similarity and how about encoding we
have seen one of the uh simplest way to
encode a node that is through a shallow
encoder or embedding loot cap so in this
uh shallow encoder we have embedding
Matrix and one column of the embeding
Matrix represent one node and the
dimension of the embeding Matrix
represent the size of the no of the node
embedding and we we talk about the
embedding lot cap which means that we
will uh to to represent the Noe we will
pick one column in The embeding Matrix
and get that Vector as the node
representation so this is the shallow
encoder
idea so what are the issues of this
Shadow encoder well uh we list three key
limitations the first is that um this
way of encoding noes is not really
scalable because we assign one learnable
uh Vector for each node so in total
there will be uh to the order of V times
D this large number of uh parameters and
it wouldn't work for a real world large
graph say it has um billions of nodes
and another limitation is that this
approach is in transas trans
transductive uh which means that the
encoder can only apply to the noes that
have seen during training time so
suppose we have this embedding Matrix
but there's a new node that comes we do
we do not know how to encode that new
node that because it's not even in the
ining Matrix and lastly this approach
does not incorporate no attributes so in
real world graph the attributes and
notes are usually very valuable for
example in protein interaction graphs we
have a lot of protein properties uh that
can be associated with a given note so
without that uh attributes we wouldn't
be able to meaningfully learn from the
network but this kind of encoding uh
loap ining l cap we wouldn't be able to
utilize such valuable
attributes so these are the limitations
uh for shadow encoder and that's why
today we want to dive deeper into how we
can design more expressive more powerful
encoders and our idea is to use deep
graph encoder and the idea is that
rather than using a symbol uh embedding
lot cap we will Define multiple layers
of uh neuron Network Transformations and
use that deep neuron Network to encode a
a node in the graph and not that um
these de colors can be combined with the
no similarity function that we have just
introduced for example we can also
Define some sort of uh random work based
similarity function even for the de
coder that will later introduced
today so here is our plan the pipeline
of how to encode a a deep graph uh
encoder so our input will be a complex
Network we will pass it through several
graph convolutional layers um between
these layers we can inject uh for
example activation functions and then
some regularization layers um and after
Computing uh this through this D encoder
we will get output the output could be
node embeddings which we most commonly
seen but we can also generate say
embeddings for subgraph and even
embedding for entire graphs so these are
the some options that we can use to uh
generate uh through this deep graph
encoder so suppose we have this encoder
what we can do well we can Define many
exciting task on graphs and here at
least four different levels on the Node
level we can use this idea to encode
different nodes and make not
classification uh for example suppose we
have a a drug protein interaction
Network and then we can predict whether
this drug is toxic or not or whether can
be used to uh treat a given disease uh
we can also Define link prediction on
network and Link PR can be quite useful
for say recommended systems where we can
define an interaction Network between
users and items and we can predict
whether a user will buy a certain item
and we can also Define community
detection over Network
and this can be useful say for financial
networks where we can have a cluster of
U frosters and they may have some fishy
transactions between each other and our
goal is to detect those kind of anomaly
clusters in the network and finally we
can Define uh Network similarity task in
that case it will be a graph level task
or graph level prediction for example we
can use this idea to encode different
drug molecules so here we treat a
molecule as a network
and we want to classify uh different
types of molecules so this are just a
like a glipse of different ways you can
um Define machine learning task on
graphs okay so so far we have motivated
you that why we want to use um deep uh
encoders to encode graph and we'll start
by uh just taking a very brief uh
introduction of basics of deep learning
um and a lot of course materials are
also posted online uh in this lecture we
wouldn't cover all of them so because we
assume that most of you are already have
some idea of deep learning U but you if
you feel not like a very confident of
the materials please take a look on the
website and also we have this recitation
and Al uh office hours so uh you can
also ask Tas about specific questions
about um uh deep learning Basics so here
I would just uh summarize some of the
key ideas that we probably want to uh
use in today's lecture so so our idea is
to formulate machine learning as a
optimization problem this optimization
problem has an input X and the goal is
to predict uh the label Y and the input
X can be uh different data modalities
such as vectors sequences uh matrices
and today we'll talk about graphs and
we'll formulate this task as an
optimization
problem and the problem looks like this
our goal is to find a uh optimal
parameter SATA such that it can um
minimize the loss function the loss
function will involve labels and
predictions and SATA is just a parameter
that we want to learn and it could be
the weight matrices uh in a deep neural
network um and also in this shallow
encoder uh example the uh seta uh is
like a uh the entire embedding Matrix
that we learn
over and we can also Define different
type of loss function depending on the
type of task we care about for example
for regression task we us use L2 loss
and uh shown here and for classification
task we also use U like a cross entropy
loss here so one useful resource is uh
this uh link of py TCH which give both
thetical and concrete implementation
examples of a bunch of useful loss
functions for deep learning so um so we
suggest you to take a look um and this
will also be useful for your uh collab
and potential course
project
and another concept will usually pop up
in the lecture and we'll just use the
acronym MLP so uh MLP is really
multi-layer perception and it usually
can be written as this so we have the
input x uh the uh upper uh L means that
we consider the input for the L layer of
the network we will apply a linear
transformation for the input and then uh
plus the bias which is also trainable we
will apply some nonlinear activation
function which could be Ru or sigmoid
and then uh we get the output so this
layer is pretty simple but it's really
the building block for tons of useful
deeping architectures um for example in
graph Network and also even in other
domains like even Transformer we have
MLP to do the linear or nonlinear
projections
Etc um and here's a concrete example uh
suppose we have a two dimensional input
to an MLP
uh you see there are two neurons here uh
we will apply different uh intermediate
layer in MLP uh for example
threedimensional like a hidden layer
here and the output will be one
dimension so this is like a very
frequently used uh like a module in deep
learning
architectures and to summarize uh we
formulate machine learning as an
optimization problem about finding the
optimum SATA for a deep neural network
and uh F can can be anything can be a
linear layer MLP or complex graph neur
Network the way we train it is through
propagate uh propagation where we first
uh forward propagate to make inference
to make predictions and then we perform
back propagate to optimize and find the
optimum seta and we'll use thetic
gradient descend to optimiz seta over
many
iterations and yeah that's the uh basic
idea of uh deep
learning so uh let's jump in into more
exciting topic today that is about deep
learning for graphs how can we uh Define
that Paradigm particularly for graph C
data so here's our plan or the summary
of our content uh we'll have two major
steps to define a full deep learning on
graph Network we'll first consider the
local network structure uh where where
we'll describe the aggregation function
which tells us how we summarize
information about the local neighborhood
of a node
and then we'll Define the concrete
computational graph to um execute the uh
computation and having defined this uh
setup we spe specify a concrete
computable architecture which involves
multiple layers uh and also we'll talk
about how do we train this model and how
find some examples about un superise and
superise learning on this deep graph
Learning
Network so let's begin with uh the setup
uh we assume that we are
provided with a graph as the input to
this uh deep graph learning model um
graph can be defined as follow we have V
as the vertex set and a as the adjacency
Matrix uh we assume adjacent Matrix us
binary um and X is the Matrix of node
feature um we have uh like the cality of
V which is number of node times d uh as
the two Dimensions D is the feature
dimension of the
input uh we represent a small lowercase
V is a node in the node or vertex set
and the neighborhood function of v
defines the set of direct neighbors um
of a given node in the
graph uh a very useful uh like a
attribute is uh we have node features
Associated noes so we don't just plainly
have nodes in the network we also
associate a lot of meaningful features
for a given node for example in Social
Network we can associate uh user profile
images of product those kind of attribut
associated with noes and for biological
networks we can use uh GM expression
profiles and some Gene function
information Etc a lot of useful uh
attributes as well and you can also
Imagine there are cases where we don't
have not feature in the graph data set
either they are missing or we simply
don't know about them so there are also
ways to deal with that kind of failure
cases uh in that way either we can use
an indicator Vector for example one one
H encoding of node so suppose we have a
five noes in the graph we can have a
five dimensional one hard encoding label
the noes as 1 2 35 um that way we can
get some initialization or initial
featur encoding we can also consider
using constant as no feature uh in that
case we'll just use a constant one for
all the no in network just showing that
all the noes are treated equally and
they don't really carry uh too much
additional information so these are the
ways suppose you don't have no feature
in the graph data set
so after introducing this uh question
can you go back one SL um so in the case
of like vector Conant how you decide
what the demand should be for
the yeah good question so the question
is suppose we don't know um no feature
and we want to impute um uh we want to
insert this like a constant Vector here
what is dimension um I think is
essentially uh having a one dimensional
basic scalar is sufficient here because
it really doesn't uh carry much meaning
here and the only purpose we want to
have this feature is that it can be uh
easily processed by a new neur network
and a constant one means that all the
nodes are treated equally so you can
imagine you can assign different value
to noes but that kind of carry some
additional prior information so let's
say um like given Network we can assign
A and B with different values so that
basically mean you could differentiate
this two noes in the network so um this
like initialized initialization means
how you will like a treat or value
different no in the
graph uh question so how do we copy Edge
feature the training yeah a great
question so in this setup we kind of
simplify the case where we do not expl
uh add features so we say we assume the
adjac symetrix is binary but you can
also Al imagine there are meaningful
Edge features for example um we have
user item interaction graph user may
click an item they may buy purchase an
item so there are different Edge types
in that case we can expand the adjacent
Matrix so rather than making it to be
binary we can make it like a more
meaningful for example can be like a
categorical value where different values
means different uh type of edges so
that's one way you can extend to
attributes okay
um any more
question okay um so this is like the
setup for graph deep learning and let's
see suppose we don't learn or we haven't
learned this lecture and what you may
consider to learn from a graph using
deep learning well uh the most uh
straightforward way to consider is
because we have a adjacent Matrix we
have a node feature Matrix so it will be
natural that we can concatenate this two
Matrix together and then we can apply
the simplest uh deep learning method
which is MLP which has introduced and we
throw this like a concatenate Matrix of
a graph into an MLP and see how it will
predict so this pattern uh can be
implemented and you may work in certain
cases but there are some uh notable
issues first is that uh this approach is
not really scalable because you can see
the input Dimension is to the order of
number of nodes and we also have
additional feature Dimension D so the um
like the complexity here is the order of
uh uh V *
D and also this kind of approach is not
really appical to graphs with different
sizes because the input Dimension will
vary based on the number of nodes so if
you train a network on five node graph
and you couldn't really apply the same
network to a six node graph so this also
kind of limiting and and finally that
approach is very sensitive to node
ordering so suppose we have the same
network but we re reorder the node so
instead of calling it a to e we may say
say call it e to a and all the values
here will be shuffled as well and you
can see in that case the output will be
different so these are kind of
limitations tell us we couldn't directly
Define uh a graph learning method based
on the standard deing block rather that
we need to Define specific architecture
for graph
data uh another thing we may consider in
our toolbox isolution neural network
because you see um for convolution
Network you can easily process imagery
data and in fact in all the materials we
visualize a graph as an image so it will
be naturally to see that we can uh like
a pad or like a down sample the graph
into the 2D space and then use CNN to
process the graph data and actually in
the early days in deep learning
researchers have done that um and it
actually works in some cases for example
molecular classification those kind of
task where graphs are relatively simple
but um our uh the issue is uh the
network doesn't have the regular
structure as images so you can see that
Network could be very complex in its
structure and most notably it doesn't
have the fixed notion of locality in
this case so what I mean that for
example here you may think um these two
nodes are close together or these two
nodes are close together but in reality
maybe the node that are far away they
are also very close together with the
note here because they are connected so
you have tons of options about how to
visualize a network into an image so
that give you a lot of freedom but also
uh prevent a mod to meaningfully learn
from Network and also um graph is
permutation environment because graph is
an unordered object so um so even though
you have this like a Comal future
patched here you may arbitrarily shaffle
the order of the node and the meaning
doesn't change but the CN network will
treat it differently so this is kind of
like a s experiment that shows why we
couldn't directly apply CN on
graphs so let's discuss what are the
property we really need for deep
learning methods for graph let's start
with the first property that is So-Cal
permutation invariance the idea of
permutation invariance is that we know
that graph does not have a conical
ordering and we can have arbitrary order
plans for a given Network here's a
concrete example uh we can have uh this
network as a running example we Define a
specific node oring uh here and we can
Define the corresponding node features
and adjacent Matrix basically describe
how this graph uh looks
like and in the pin time we can Shuffle
the order of the note here so we can
come with a second way to order the
graph and you see that after this
shuffling or permutation the node
feature Matrix and adjacent Matrix they
get
different and our idea is that because
we know these two other plants describe
the same network what we wish to say is
that the graph and no representations
for these two other plants but for the
same network they should be same they
should be identical so this is kind of
our goal when we want to define a deep
learning method for
graphs so let's uh describe this
peration in variance property more
rigorously so what do we mean by um like
the graph impation are the same so we
can Define like a projection function or
embedding function f that takes the
adjacency Matrix a and the uh node
feature Matrix X and what we say is that
we can have two different order plan for
the network A1 X1 and A2 X2 and suppose
we uh take this input to the same
encoding function f we want the output
to be the same so that basically says uh
suppose we have two ordering of the same
network we want a encoding function f
which is say a graph NE Network should
always generate the same representation
for the same graph this is like a
visually say like a the two order plans
the output F should be the
same and we also formally uh defin it uh
like a here that like basically U for
per envirment we not only for two two
ordering like Order Plan a and Order
Plan B we should consider any potential
like Order Plan I and J and we formally
say that supposed it's per then for any
pair of I and J the output should be the
same we can also view this as in The
Matrix form so we Define a graph
function that essentially map a node
feature Matrix R uh into the order of a
uh V * m and the adjacent Matrix to a
vector space and we say this function f
is permission invariant uh if we wrote
In The Matrix form a and X as the input
and will permute The adjacency Matrix
and permute um the feature Matrix and
the output are the same for any
permutation P then we say um this
function is permutation in so the same
thing we can express it in different
ways but this is kind of definition of
permutation
invariance another concept here is
permutation equivariance so here is a
different term uh with invariance we
talk about the idea of VAR so what does
it mean um we talk about uh we can
encode a graph into a graph
representation where we have one vector
for the graph now we are considering the
representation in the node level so
instead of having one vector we will
have one vector for each node in the
graph and in the end we will have an
embedding or output Matrix for the
network so now the output instead of
being a vector it will be a matrix so
what is the nice property we wish to see
here well um we got the same network and
we permute uh the order of the notes
therefore we would like to see that the
values or the encoded values for
different noes they should be the same
but the order should be according to the
position of the node in the network here
is a uh illustrative
example um so let's say let's say we
care about this yellow node and in the
first order plan the yellow node is
labeled as a and it appeared here and
our hope is that because we only shaffle
the order of the node so the encoding of
the yellow Noe should be the same and it
should appear in the C the latest
encoding of the second order plan e so
it says that the encoding for no should
stay the same and it's only based on how
the node is labeled it should always
associated with the node label a and
node label e and the same is for all the
other nodes in the network let's say
another example for example for a green
mode is here is label as C and here is
label as D and suppose we have this nice
equivariance property then after we
Shuffle the node ordering the value
should stay the same and it is closely
tied to the label of the
node we can also formula Define what is
permission equivalent that basically
says um if the output Vector of a node
at the same position in the graph remain
unchange for any peration
and we say this function is peret
equivalent and we can also see this in
the Matrix form so now we Define instead
of a graph function we Define a node
function that encode a network into a
matrix instead of the single vector and
this Matrix uh is permutation equivalent
sorry this function is permutation
equivalent if we permute input uh input
uh of adjacent Matrix of node feature
Matrix and the output Matrix is also
permuted accordingly with the
permutation Matrix p in that case we say
this function is permutation
equiv so we talk about these two
properties it would be nice to review
them and compare these two properties so
here I show the definition the matrix
definition of uh invariant and
equivariant um in plain language what
does it really mean is that um so suppos
we permute the input then the output
will always uh stay the same this is for
permutation in variant and the output
here is usually a vector so we assign
one vector for one graph and we can also
Define a plain language definition for
equivariant where we if we permute the
input the output also get permitted uh
sorry accordingly and in that case this
is um usually considering a case where
we map a graph into a matrix and the
Matrix talk about the embedding Vector
for each of the node and here are three
concrete examples of what functions are
invariant and what functions are
equivalent the first example is this
like a one vector transpose time x is
basically a summation over a matrix over
different rows and in that case you can
easily see the function is perimeter
invariant because it is summation so no
matter how you permute the input x uh
the output will stay the
same uh here here's another example
which is per equivalent which is pretty
simple so we just output always output
the node um input uh X this is basically
the uh shallow encoder that we see right
we have a encoder Matrix and essentially
is the output in and it's easy to see
it's equivalent because if you permute
the input of course the output get
permuted uh
equivalently and finally we have example
of this a * X as a permutation
equivalent function and here we use the
property of that suppose you transpose a
matrix and then transpose it with it um
and then times with it transpose you'll
cancel out into an identity function and
uh you see this function is also
permutation equivalent and this idea of
a time x is uh like a simplest version
of graph learning or uh like graph
message aggregation and we'll talk about
this later as
well so uh any question here I know the
concept A bit dense here
what is
exactly yeah
so we
have what does it look like MH um yeah
uh we didn't have a visual license here
uh but it's really like a binary Matrix
it has zero has ones and um it basically
said How We Shuffle different Columns of
a network uh of a matrix sorry um right
let's see um suppose um
uh we have a matrix of six rows then the
peration Matrix will also be 6X six and
different locations of one and zero says
how where we should put uh the a uh
input a to the output so let's say if we
have um uh like a 0 one uh one zero then
that means we'll Shuffle A and B so like
this is idea of peration matrix and you
can also search on the web for more
yeah and any other
questions okay um we can uh
continue so why do we want to study
these two properties of invariance and
equivariance that is because uh these
properties are pretty important and
essentially the key building blocks for
graph learning method so I show an
example of graph learning method here
and you can see that it usually involves
multiple permutation equant layers and
permutation invar layers
and this is kind of how we make sure uh
graph Dearing method can uh face F
represent the graph rather than like a
mess it up like an MLP that we like
introduced
earlier and and here's like a a visual
example like why MLP doesn't satisfy
this property so suppose we have an MLP
and then we have this Vector uh as input
and we permute the values of this vector
um you see and after throwing it into an
MLP then it clear that the output will
be different because it doesn't really
have the um the way to say aggregate it
in a per invariant way so the output
will always be
different and this is precisely why this
naive MLP approach to try to encode a
network would fail um because it doesn't
have this nice property of peration
invariance
uh next I'm going to talk about how do
we specifically Define a graph in your
network with these two properties and in
particular we'll talk about passing and
um message message information on the
neighbors question sorry you go to the
previous Slide m so I mean it feels like
this is a problem that would come up for
like trying to create a neural network
for any kind of unstructured data right
where like ordering not important so
like this graph Neal networks's the
first time it came up or like was it
seen before M yeah that's a good
question so uh the question is about
like can we use the graph learning
method to incode other unordered objects
and where this IDE original from and and
yeah I think uh the idea of graph
learning method as we also dive into
deepal later uh is inspired from a
learning from a set so essentially a
neighbor uh the set of neighbors of a
given node is a set and suppose we have
a meage to learn from set essentially we
can uh build a complete graph learning
method so it definitely also have rootes
in other areas of deep
learning
okay okay um uh let's continue with our
discussion so so far we have talked
about the motivation of graph de
learning and the the required properties
that we wish to see in the graph de
learning method uh next I'm going to
talk about concrete example uh that is
so-call graph convolutional networks and
this is arguably the most popular uh way
to encode a graph and the most popular
uh way to implement a graph new
network so here's idea of a graph
convolutional neuron network uh our idea
is to encode a note based on its
neighborhood structure and we follow a
two-step process suppose we want to
encode node I in the network we will
first Define is a computational graph
based on the no local neighborhood
structure so we will Define based on it
oneop neighbors and the neb of neighbors
and so on suppose we have multiple
layers and then having defined this
computational graph we will propagate
and transform information based on the
defined computational graph and the key
concept here is that how we can learn
and propagate information across the
network uh defined by the node
neighborhood
structure so we will uh introduce the
idea through a running example this is
an input graph and our goal is to encode
this yellow node a
based on the idea I just described we
will enroll the computational graph by
uh finding the a direct Neighbors in the
network uh b c uh and d and then we'll
iteratively enroll the neighbor
structure for each of its neighbor so
for node B we will see it neighbors A
and C for node C we see uh neighbors and
so on so we can imagine this enrolling
can happen iteratively until um you
reach the number of round you wish to
see that is the number of layers in the
network and another thing to note that
uh a node can appear multiple times in
this computational graph what do I mean
that you can see node a it will also
appear uh here like a a uh three times
the the interpretation here is that node
a is a two neighbor of itself so if you
look two half away for a given node you
will encounter the node itself again so
it is that we can have this duplicate
value in the computational
graph so uh having defined a
architecture of the computation how do
we really implement we have these uh
different gray boxes which are
essentially neuron Network what does
this neuron do is to compress or
condense the information about a set of
different nodes and then we will
generate uh new representation and then
compress it again
so this is like a what where neuron
network will help for graph learning
method in
GN and we can repeat this process and
Define the compostition graph for each
node in the network so we'll talk about
this yellow node but you see we can
Define competition graph for each node
in a graph and um the intuition here is
that different node will have a
different competition graph because
their local neighborhood structure are
different and this is precise how graph
learning methods can differentiate noes
in a network because they have different
neighborhood structure we will Define
different computational graph and
therefore the embedding we generate for
different notes are also
different um question is it true the
statement that let's say for a given for
a problem of um of not embedding um the
the higher the degree is the more
complicated the embedding would be
meaning that nodes that are not that
don't have a lot of neighbors are are
more easily to to embed because we see
here the embedding basically scales with
the neighbors right so if there's one
neighbor it's an easy embedding if we
have a thousand neighbors it's like to
embed all that information if you want
know there a lot yeah that's a great
question uh I think your question is
talk about like a is like a node with
fewer neighbor easier to encode um uh
well I think rigor say we we need to
Define what it easy mean but I think
intuitively um like a a not way with
fewer enables uh it takes like a fewer
information and it will be more easily
to be compressed and there's actually a
frontier of a GN that describ problem
called a so-call over scratching problem
because you can see that uh for GN is
always talk about how to scratch
information uh together and like that
problem definitely basically said
suppose a network is very deep and the
degree of a note is very high like a the
network May tend to over scratch uh like
this information of the network and your
intution here is correct in the sense
that if the node has fewer neighbor then
it's easier to uh uh get the
embedding um okay um let's
continue and another concept here is the
number of layers uh in my example here
um we have a two layer uh graph neural
network which basically said uh we look
at the neighbors and the neighbors of
Neighbors
and this concept uh is quite important
for GN because the number of layer of GN
really tells about how far away we look
in the network so given a two layer GN
we'll usually be able to see like the
nose there are two HS away so this is
kind of different with other depl
architecture say in convolution neural
network the number of layer is usually
just a hyperparameter right you can pick
uh whenever uh like the model is
performing the best but for GN it has a
concrete physical meaning the number of
G layers tells us how far away you can
see in the network and usually we will
peck the number of layer approximately
equal to the diameter of the graph so in
this graph we have diameter two which
means that uh two nod can at most have
like a a distance of two for any pair of
nodes in the network so in this case
usually having a two- layer uh G will be
sufficient for the network to pick up
the essential information in the network
so uh setting the um like we can have
this kind of more principal way to set
number of layers for graph NE
Network and uh we also have the concept
of neighborhood aggregation which is
done by this great brockus uh in the uh
example here so the question is how do
we really Define this
boxes the most simple approach is to
take an average of the
information um uh to be more specific we
can first average the message that we
compute for each neighbor of a given
node and then we'll apply a a NE Network
that further transform this uh aggregate
or average information and this two sty
process is essentially what we will
later see in a graph convolutional
Network um so here is like the math
mathematical uh there's a question yeah
can you go back one SL
uh yeah it's sorry here is good so if
you said for example he will end up
choosing let's say K2 the neighborhoods
so two convolutional uh layers but we
see all the nodes basically if we go two
pops away we'll end up having all the
other nodes as as a part of their
embedding process as inputs so don't all
the nodes end up having this like very
similar
representations when after after
2K yeah yeah yeah I think you as a lot
of inside of questions uh the question
is um suppose uh we enroll the network
and we look at the computation graph for
each of the noes uh wouldn't in the end
all notes look similar so we talk about
this over squashing problem for GN
another research uh idea here is So-Cal
over smoothing problem uh which is
precisely what we described so suppose
we enroll this process continuously for
multiple layers and in the end all the
nodes they have very similar
neighborhood structure and which makes
them indistinguishable so they all
landed with the same embedding so this
is also like a research question but
usually the way we can get rid of this
over smoothing problem is to do not like
set very deep GN like we just set a
number of layers uh equal or approximate
the diameter of the network and in that
case like in the example we show here
usually the computational graph of
different noes are largely the same but
suppose you continuously enroll and row
um multiple layers um you may face the
issue that all the noes may look almost
the same and we couldn't differentiate
so this is kind of different with like
convolutional neuronet or rest net where
you can enroll I don't know 150 layers
for graph if you unroll 100 layers and
essentially the model will learn nothing
because it can differentiate any
noes okay so we have a lot of
visualizations now we can get some
concrete mathematical definition of what
exactly is a graph convolutional Network
so our input is node attributes um XV so
this that describe a specific feature of
a given node um and by the way to uh
make this competition more concrete we
consider a case of embedding a single
node V so you see all the um expression
here we have this uh subscri uh V and
the output is this d v so we have a node
attribute and we want to generate
embedding D for this given node
V so how do we uh start this computation
we will assign this XV uh to the uh h v
zero which is basically the zero layer
or like the initialization for the uh
input of a graph neural network and then
we'll repeatedly uh apply this
transformation so what this
transformation does
is it will first take the embedding of
wi of the previous layer
K and then we also take the average of
the neighbors previous layer embedding
so in this uh transformation we do two
things we consider how do we represent
the note itself in the previous layer
and after we get that embedding we'll
apply a linear transformation to uh
encode or transform that message the
second question we ask is how do we repr
The Neighbors of a given note and in
that case we will first take the average
and we normalize uh by the like a the
neighbor size with degree of the node
and after we take the average we then
apply another transformation uh W then
tell us how to transform and further
encode the neighbors information so the
there is usually just uh is essentially
just two parts how do we encode the node
itself and how do we encode the no's
neighbors uh and after having this
encoding because it's a fully linear
function if you stack linear function
again again is still linear we have to
have enerve some nonlinearity here the
most popular chice is uh Ru which is
also popular in other de architecture so
this basically Define how we compute one
layer of GNN and in practice we'll have
multiple layers where K describe the
number of total layers so we'll iterate
apply this GNN on the
input where the zero layer of um graph
embedding and then in the end we'll get
the embedding after K runs computation
and this is U uh can be expressed as
doing K runs of neighborhood
aggregation and notice that here this
because we use summation um this
functions uh permutation invariant so
this follows the nice property that we
follow that we discussed uh for any
graph learning method
um any question
here why why did you use U average of
neighbor previously embed versus the
just the neighbor um raw features like
like or like the embeding of the
neighbor at layer
zero um so the question is why don't we
average the input feature instead
of just neighbor previous layer ining um
and wondering why would wouldn't you
choose um the layer
zero um
yeah I see so your suggesting that
instead of uh just look at the pr layer
in Bedding we can also look at the zero
layer the initialization in Bedding yeah
cuz to me it sounds like um you're
adding this note at this step so it
doesn't quite make sense to um like look
at all the previous case
that U well so first the motivation here
is that we want to have So-Cal deep
presentation or like inter leave
complexation for node so that's why we
have to like iteratively like a generate
embedding and then feed into the next
layer so suppose here we replace this
representation with the zero layer then
the uh embedding So-Cal shallow because
you never go beyond like a one layer
Network you directly transform the input
um Zer
layer um but I think your idea is
actually uh in like helpful we're seeing
in some of the literature uh where um
probably um some of you know the notion
of dense net so essentially your
suggestion is that uh during computation
we always associate competion with the
raw input uh Z layer and you can
consider in the network um
representation we have a stack of
multiple layers but then uh in the in
each layer will connect it back to the
input and I think that kind of one
interpretation of your suggestion um I
think yeah it's kind of also valuable uh
but in this basic version of GM we just
uh just use a previous
layer um any other
questions
okay so yeah basically this is the most
Den slide in this lecture that describe
what is gcn looks
like so we talk about uh permutation
equivariance and permutation invariance
and let's uh see or uh like check
whether the network we have defined
follows these two properties so let's
first talk about permutation in property
so uh the argument is as follows so
given a node in the network the gcn that
comput is embedding is permutation
invariant um our example is to embed
this blue node and we say uh this
competition for given node embedding is
Perman invalent because two reasons
first we make sure that we share the new
network weights when we transform the
neighbors of of a given node and second
when we take this aggregation we make
sure that aggregation is permutation
Inver for example just a summation and
due to these two reasons we can conclude
that this full computation computational
graph is also permutation
invariant so why this properly is uh
like a interesting or like a non-trivial
that's because um we can also consider
Define uh competition differently and in
fact in the in early like literature of
GNN people have tried other ways of
Performing the aggregation of neighbors
and they may perform well but they don't
really like follow the peration inir
property so another popular chice in at
that time was to use a recurrent neuron
Network to encode a set of
noes so in that case suppose we have
neighbors BCD they will throw BCD as a
sequence and throw it into a recurrent
neet and use the output as the like
encoded value and although this idea
like makes sense it doesn't really
follow this per in property um and in
our case we can use this Shar neur race
uh plus uh like a some aggregation to
make sure the computation is permutation
inent uh another property check is
peration equivalence and our argument is
as follows um consider when we try to
incode all the nodes in the network so
we not just uh previously we focus of uh
encoding one node say this blue node now
suppose we want to consider the uh
embedding function for a no in the
network we claim that this uh embedding
function is permutation
equivalent and just to remind you what
is equivalent mean is that suppose we
have this same network but with two
different ordering plan and we can check
um suppose we after the peration um the
same node will have the same encoded
value but only their Position will diff
differ
accordingly uh so what is the reasoning
why this is true for g&n this is uh
because two reasons first is that we
make sure the feature Matrix and the EMB
embedding are closely aligned what do I
mean is that here we always make sure
the first row is talking about node a in
the both the input node feature and the
output node embedding and the second row
is about node B and uh and third row is
node C Etc and the second reason is that
we showed that given a node when we
apply a g&n is permutation invariant so
after permuting the noes the color which
represent the value of the embedding is
always the same because of this Inver
property so given these two reasons
suppose we shuffled the order of a Noe
in the network we can see globally it uh
present this compation equivalent
property so why does this property also
important that is because um in our case
we want to encode all the nodes in the
network and we want to have a reliable
way to extract the embedding for a given
note suppose we uh comput embeddings in
parallel what could be the failure mode
is that we may correctly embed each
nodes so a to F we get their embeddings
but we may get like a wrong order of the
embedding so instead of having them
access align so the first row know a
second R know B we may get them like a
wrong like for the third row may talk
about node a so even though we get
globally um the set of embeding correct
their ordering may be wrong so the
property of perp equivalent ensures that
we always can um reliably get the
embedding for a given note so this uh
this property is also non-trivial and
really important for
GN okay uh we can move forward so so far
we have defined the mo most of graph
neural network and next I'm going to
talk about how do we train such a
network so uh to train network uh really
the key is to define a loss function and
based on the embedding D that we
get so uh what are uh our like a
training um pipeline or training
procedure looks like uh this is the same
definition of gcn that we have just seen
we have two main trainable parameter
here
W and B where we talk about to
understand this equation we talk about
how to encode the note itself and how to
encode the no's neighbors so node B
tells how do we transform and process
the information of the node itself and
no uh this uh Matrix W talks about how
to encode the neighbors of the given
node um so these are the trainable
parameter and then we can feed the
output uh of the no bedding into any
loss function that you can see so in the
beginning of review we talk about L2 LW
for regression and cross entropy law for
classification so you can define those
uh loss function uh based on the
computed no
embedding and another um uh sorry
question yeah can go back one
slly no not this one sorry back this is
forward okay another
one wait you mean the the one where
there's like the embedding on the
right here we go so let's say if this is
a classification case and we have these
two representation of the the network
and it's the same network in the end of
the day how do we make sure that eding
H1 and eding H2 end up with the same
output let's say that it's
whatever Class A so we just like St
stack them up then as one vector just
then do some kind of summation and then
that's it or how how do we how do we go
from these embeddings to a to a
specification yeah um actually in the
following side we will talk about that
but the idea is that um for a given node
we get a vector right we can have a for
example additional layer that project
this Vector into a single score the
score can tells that the predicted class
of that uh like a Noe for example is a
binary classification we have true or
false then we can project this two
dimensional Vector into a single scaler
from range of 0 to one and that can
tells us how we want to classify this
given
node but that itself should also be
aimation or something where the order
doesn't matter right because we want H1
and H2 to have the same numerical value
when you when we go through that
function oh yeah so I think here I want
to clarified um because we want to
define a note classification problem so
the label are not directly associate
with the embedding Matrix but uh asso
with a particular node so for example we
know node C sorry we know this blue node
is associated with like a uh like a
label of one so it's not uh related to
the order of the node but we always find
this blue node and then assign a order a
label of one to the node and this way we
can um always reliably associate a node
with label and then train the network
regardless of how we order the different
noes okay um any other
question okay so uh we talk about uh
training a graph neur Network and then
uh the goal is to optimize this weight
matrices uh based on the uh
embedding and another important topic uh
here is how can we um efficiently U
train or optimize this um GM the reason
that the ESS of mod de learning is
really rely on Parallel Computing uh GPU
acceleration so earlier our formulation
was like a local level so we only
consider how to compute ining for a
given node but we didn't really talk
about how to paralyze that algorithm so
now our goal is to ritten the definition
of GN but now in The Matrix form and
suppose we can written it in The Matrix
form then we can easily utilize those
parallel Computing device to accelerate
the training process so here is our idea
so earlier we talk about uh the core of
neighborhood aggregation is about
summing the neighbors of a given note
and we can equivalently written it or
write it into a matrix form which is
essentially a * H where a is the
adjacency Matrix but we particularly
look at a row that describ not V and
then H is the uh Matrix that describe
the embedding for all the nodes in the
network and another
notion is this D which is a diagonal
matrix that tells about the degree of
each node in the
network uh we can use the inverse of d
uh to express like the inverse of the no
degree and based on these two uh Matrix
that we defined we can write this
aggregation function which tells us we
want to um take the average of each node
neighbors into its Matrix form where we
have this uh D inverse
* a * H so you can check that these two
equations are the same and this way we
can express this local wheel of GN into
this Global Matrix
wheel so follow this idea we can
additionally um write the entire
transformation of g&n into its Matrix
form so now we have this um a * H * W
and H * B which uh basically describe
how we transform the no's neighbors and
transform the node itself in a global
wheew um and so the red one talks about
how to aggregate the neighbors the blue
term talks about how to transform the
node itself and in practice this implies
that we can efficiently compute GNN not
in a local perspective but really in the
global sparse Matrix M multiplication
perspective and this can be uh like a
very helpful because suppose we can
accelerate
Spar matrix multiplication essentially
you can accelerate any graph learning
algorithm and there's a site note like a
that is kind of Contra said that is not
every GN can be written in this Matrix
form so because the aggregation function
can be more complex so what are some uh
examples um so for example when we
perform the aggregation instead of
instead of taking the average of the
neighbors you can consider taking the
maximum of the neighbors because this
maximum operator cannot be written in
this Matrix form we cannot really
succinctly write it in the this uh
Matrix uh expression and couldn't really
benefit from this U spish matrix
multiplication okay so we talk about how
to efficiently train a network uh next
I'm going to give some concrete example
of uh like how to train under the
concrete mure learning setting uh as you
probably know there are two major
Paradigm of machine learning that is
supress learning and npress learning in
suest learning we have a concrete label
associated with a graph and let's say
for example we have a node label for
each node and then we can define a loss
function based on the type of
classification or regression and
alternatively we can consider the N
surise learning Paradigm for graphs
where in this case we don't have any
particular external label for a node but
uh instead we can use the graph
structure itself as the
supervision so um here is like an
example of an unise learning uh
technique and this idea is actually very
related what we learned in the previous
lecture about random work embedding so
in this case the L function will take
two node embedding as input so embedding
for node U and no V we will have a
decoder function which is an for example
an inner product and then will compare
this prediction with a Noe label y u v
so how do we label the PA node UV the
idea is that we can label it based on
node similarity so suppose a pair of
node is similar considered similar then
we label them as one and if it's not we
label them as zero and how do we Define
a similarity it can be precisely what we
uh teach uh in the previous lecture for
example in random work suppose two notes
co-occur in work then we assign a label
one to this pair of node and uh like if
it's not assign zero we can also use the
idea of matrix factorization we also
mentioned in the preious lecture and in
that case uh we aim to reconstruct the
next World structure so suppos two noes
they are direct neighbors of each other
we can label them as one and if not we
can level zero we can additionally use a
node proximity in the graph for example
if two nodes are two two H neighbor in
the network we can label them as two
three half neighbor as three so there
are a lot of like a creative way that
you can Define this um um labels and
then use them as self software learning
uh objectives for graphs um an
alternatively term for this idea is
so-called self surise learning so we
want to use the graph structure itself
to create a supervision for a network
and software learn also have a lot of
other use cases in the deep learning
application but in a in graph it will be
pretty exciting because you can Define
very complex and very interesting
objectives on graphs so this is the idea
how we can do n super learning on graph
if you don't have any
labels
okay so uh here's a like visualization
for um a concrete superise learning
example um so in this case um suppose we
have a drug drug interaction Network and
we want to classify a given node whether
it's toxic or not and we get a
particular label for that node then what
we can do is that we can get the
embedding of that node DV and throw it
into this um loss function and this loss
function is really a binary cross
entropy loss that are widely used for
classification and so here DV is the
encoder output from graph new network
and we have some classification weights
to weight this like a final layer
embedding into a scaler and then we can
optimize based on this uh binary cross
cross entropy loss and this loss
function what is really saying that
because we want to minimize the loss is
that like there's an inverse here uh we
are essentially maximize the value here
and suppose this Y which is the ground
truth no Cass label suppose it take
value of one then the second term get
canceled out so our idea is want to we
want to maximize the predictive value so
suppose a class label is one then we
want to maximize the prediction and uh
alternatively if the Cass lab is zero
the first term disappear and we only
have the second term here and we want to
have this value as low as possible to
make sure this uh entire expression uh
is maximized so suppose a c is zero then
we want to minimize the prediction so
this is like an integation of the loss
function so we have already talked about
um basically everything about uh GN so
here's like a uh end to end like a a
description of how the full pipeline may
work we have this network and we want to
embed a node
a we will Define the neighborhood
structure of node a into a computational
graph and we will be able to uh generate
this node embedding and we can then
Define the loss function that we just uh
go went over uh based on the predicted
embedding and we will train that loss
function over a set of input nodes for
example we may consider train on node
ABC in this
network and after the training uh we can
do prediction or inference
for nodes in the graph and it is worth
noticing that we can make predictions
even for nodes that we never trained on
so we train on the Node ABC but DF will
never show it to the model during
training but still we can use the train
Network to make predictions for these uh
three NC
noes and this property is so-call the
inductive learning capability inductive
learning is really about can we uh use a
train Network and generalize it to an
noes and the reason that uh a GM can
perform induct learning is because we
share the parameter in the computational
graph and because the parameter are
shared we are not bounded by how the
input uh noes look like so we can use
the same network by repurpose it to any
um andc structure in the
network so um here are some examples how
we can utilize this inductive learning
capability um we can consider train the
neuron Network in one graph but then
apply it to a new graph and this new
graph is never seen during training time
and what are some use cases for example
uh we can define a graph over protein
interaction of different organism we can
train the network in one organiz
organism that we have a precise training
label but given we have a trained model
we can generate embeddings for unseen
organism and this is quite useful say in
a biological
domain another example is that we can
use this property to predict over new
nodes in this case we have a a given
graph or a snapshot of a graph and over
time we'll get new nodes arrive into the
network and our goal is to generate
embedding for the new node um the
example use case here is very popular in
Industry uh where essentially you can
represent a lot of online networks into
a graph such as Reddit uh YouTube Etc so
suppose someone upload a new video into
the YouTube Network um this is
essentially where we a new not arrive in
the network we can use a pre-int graph
NE Network and generate embeding for
this new node so this is fully rely on
the fact that GNN is inductive um on the
contrary suppose we use the uh thing we
learn on the previous lecture say no to
back it will be hard because we wouldn't
be able to generate embedding directly
for a new node but rather we have to
perform a few iteration optimization
until we can uh generate edding for a
new node so this is the nice property of
GN uh question yeah I was wondering if
there's like any results on like if
you're successively adding new nodes to
like a pre-trained graph or like a graph
that you pre-trained on then is there a
point after you just started hearing
terms of like the the
accuracy yeah that's a great question um
I think yeah this is also like a front
here in the research the question is
about like suppose we continuously add
new nodes into the network of course
until certain point we the model
wouldn't be able to predict and how do
we find that point um yeah I think this
is like a pretty nice research question
to ask um I think usually people just
consider in practice uh what people do
in practice is that they have
um like a ongoing validation set so over
time um they will re-evaluate the
network on a hold out validation set
suppose the performance on the
validation get deteriorated then uh it
basically says the model is kind of
failing to learn over the new graph
structure and that is time when you want
to retr or fine TR the network to the
architecture to to the new
graph we only have like for example on
YouTube we only have like
One MH yeah that's a great question we
actually will talk about specific layout
of uh graph learning method in the next
lecture so stay tuned but in the
meantime I can quickly say uh usually
we'll just do the random splitting for
example given this network we may
randomly pick some of the noes as the
training node and some of them as the
validation Noe and we will make sure
during training we never see this like a
hold out no um yeah that's the basic
idea but there are lot of different
variants and we will cover in the next
lecture question you add a new node to
the network do you need to know all its
connections to the existing Network or
can you sort of like add a new node and
then predict where it should be
connected in that Network yes that's a
great question um so the question is
that um can we also predict how the new
node will connect to the existing node
um and actually there's a a bit late in
our course we have a course lecture
about deep model and that is precisely
the problem you talk about where we want
to predict how a node can connect with
each existing node and this way we can
use it to generate graph so we we know
how new node connect and we can ITA do
this to generate a full Network and yeah
that's kind of a definitely doable uh
alternatively you can think of this a
link prediction task so you want to
predict the missing link between a new
note and existing graph so yeah that's a
nice uh application yeah
um okay um we can move forward to the
last part of the lecture so far we talk
about the basis of uh deep learning on
graphs and particular architecture of
gcn and in the final part of this
lecture I want to discuss the
relationship between GN and CN because I
think uh a lot of you are already
familiar with convolution network for
images and we want to compare and argue
that actually GN is more General than CN
and it's subsumes uh subsume the
CN so uh how do we compare GN and
CN well uh this is how s works right we
have an image we can have Define a
convolution of Kernel and we'll um move
that kernel around in the input image to
generate the output feature map uh
usually we wouldn't we write it in a
like a convolutional form but now
because we just learned this idea of
aggregation aggregation over neighbors
we can equivalently write CNN into the
language that we just talked about about
how do we aggregate neighbors so we can
Define Neighbors in the image based on
the proximity of pixels so for example
given a node um and this 3x3 U image
patch uh we can Define um the eight
neighbors of given pixel um as uh as it
neighbors and also we want to not
include the note itself um and then
having defined this neighborhood we can
define a transformation W over each of
the uh input pixel and then we take the
summation and do the nonlinear uh
transformation and this is essentially
an alternative way to express a
CNN and another way to encode and
imaging data is that we simply convert
this grid like structure into a graph
and this graph can look at this so we
have a node in the center we have the
self Edge that connect node with itself
and then we can connect all the
neighboring pixels with it so
essentially now a node have nine
neighbors and we can write uh we can
define a GNN over a graph defined like
this so we reuse the um the expression
about a gcn definition like this and uh
we compare what we have with GNN and CNN
CN we we just derive it in the previous
slide we find that this two expressions
are almost identical the only difference
is that there's a uh like upper script U
here there is not that basically says
for GN we will share the parameter
across all the neighbors because we have
this permutation invariant property but
for CN we do not have that like a risk
constr TR of permutation
invance the reason is that we know the
property of location in an image and we
also want to explicit it uh explicit
express it in the network definition
more precisely in an image data set we
have uh we are aware of the relative
position of pixels for example we can
label the each neighboring pixel of a
given no given pixel has this negative
one netive uh negative one netive one Z
Etc we have their relative location and
this way we don't have to consider the
permutation environment property because
we have this very explicit ordering so
this way we can define a unique weight
for each position of the neighbors
whereas in graph because we don't have
this like a prior information of the
location of those we have to treat them
equally so we Define this permutation
invar function which share the weights
that's actually actually the only
difference between G and CN in term of
this uh grid like
data so here's a summary of further
discussing the difference um in term of
uh comparing C and GN uh first for uh GN
like the size of the filter is
predefined for CN but for GN is not
predefined uh and also we talk about um
the GN can process arbitrary graph with
different degrees for each noes um and
CN is not peration EV as we just talked
about because we know the exact position
of different noes but GN we do do not
have such information so we have this
peration inar function of aggregating
neighbors so that's everything uh we
have in this lecture uh to summarize we
talk about the basics of neuron Network
and we motivate the idea of deep uh
learning for graphs and what are the
ideal properties we want to have uh in a
graph learning method and then we'll
particularly talk about one architecture
called graph convolutional Network how
do we Define it into like a uh
aggregation of neighbors and how do we
train it and finally we talk about how
we compare G with SS um that's it for
the course and um I hope you enjoyed
it